depuis aujourd'hui ils sont liés pour
quatre mois
19 filles elles demandeurs d'emploi et
19 par un employé de la sodexo se sont
rencontrés pour la première fois il
participe à une nouvelle session de la
job academy de face qui disons que c'est
vraiment un accompagnement de rendez
vous tous les quinze jours pour vraiment
créer une dynamique
on n'est pas dans l'emploi donc c'est
clair aussi c'est important que les
bénéficiaires comprennent ça c'est que
sodexo ya on va pas les embaucher voilà
le but c'est d'avoir un regard extérieur
d'une personne qui va l'accompagner qui
valent à dynamiser elle trouvera toute
seule et elle trouve toute seule
c'est le cas de sylvie elle est en
recherche d'emploi depuis fin novembre
et souhaite rester sur saint quentin en
yvelines
en fait ça fait plusieurs années que
j'enchaîne les cdd et l'intérim
ça m'a convenu pendant un certain temps
j'ai appris plein de choses en
différents secteurs d'activité mais
maintenant j'aimerais me poser pour
aller vraiment vers un poste qui va me
convenir un secteur qui va me convenir
moi je trouve que c'est important pour
les gens qui sont en poste dans une
entreprise comme la nôtre
dd quand je dis aider c'est donner des
clés de réussite pour que les gens qui
sont difficulté ou en recherche d'emploi
on leur donne les bonnes clés de
compréhension du monde de l'entreprise
telle qu'on la vit aujourd'hui de
l'intérieur comme sylvie les filles
elles rencontreront leurs parrains et
marraines tous les quinze jours
plus de 60% des bénéficiaires ont
recommencé une activité six mois après
la fin de leur job academy